This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I love punk rock. I loved it since I was a kid in central Ohio when wearing a Hooskirdu t-shirt resulted in me being threatened by dumb jocks. I still wore that t-shirt every day because f**k them. First and foremost, I loved the music. I loved the power and the purpose it gave me.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我热爱朋克摇滚。从我在俄亥俄州中部还是个孩子时起，我就爱上了它，当时穿着一件胡斯基杜（Hüsker Dü）的T恤，结果被那些愚蠢的体育生威胁。我依然每天穿着那件T恤，因为去他们的。首先，我热爱这种音乐。我热爱它赋予我的力量和目标。
I loved reading about scenes from other cities that were way better than my dumb town. I loved everything about the punk scene. Okay, maybe not everything. One punk thing that I did not do that most of the punk and hardcore kids around me were super into was I did not ride a skateboard. In that time and in that place, punk was inextricably linked to skateboarding, but I didn't have the athleticism nor the initiative to be an actual skateboarder.
我喜欢阅读关于其他城市场景的报道，那些地方比我那个愚蠢的小镇好多了。我热爱朋克场景的一切。好吧，也许不是一切。大多数我身边的朋克和硬核小孩都非常热衷的一件事，我却没有做，那就是玩滑板。在那个时代和那个地方，朋克与滑板运动有着千丝万缕的联系，但我既没有运动天赋，也没有动力去成为一名真正的滑板手。
One person I know who loves skateboarding when he was a kid is 99 PI producer, Christopher Johnson. Hell yeah. I was super into skateboarding, especially back in the late 1980s. I think when we were both getting into punk rock. I mean, I love to skate. I watched all the skating videos.
我认识的一个从小就热爱滑板的人是《99%隐形》的制作人克里斯托弗·约翰逊。没错。我非常迷滑板，尤其是在80年代末。我想那是我们俩都开始接触朋克摇滚的时候。我是说，我喜欢滑板。我看了所有的滑板视频。
My mom got me a subscription to Thrasher Magazine, and I would lay on my bed and look through all those dope pictures of all the skaters, and I was just fascinated. I'm actually still a pretty big skateboarding fan, although now mostly just as a spectator. But you, Roman Mars, you are not into skating and you never have been. Nope, not at all. I mean, you know, I appreciate it, but no. And that's totally cool.
我妈妈给我订了《Thrasher》杂志，我会躺在床上翻看那些滑手们超酷的照片，我简直着迷了。事实上，我现在仍然是一个相当大的滑板迷，尽管现在大多只是作为观众。但你，罗曼·马尔斯，你不喜欢滑板，而且从来没喜欢过。没错，一点也不。我是说，你知道，我很欣赏它，但我不玩。这完全没问题。
But I still think you'll be into this story that I have for you today. It's about the history of the modern skateboard as an object. You've never been a skater, but you are a design nerd. And this is as much a story about design as it is about your least favorite punk subculture. They're definitely less favorite punk subcultures. But I get your point and I'm very excited. So when I watch skate videos today, it really strikes me that all of the skateboard decks that everyone is riding, they're all shaped almost exactly alike.
但我仍然认为你会喜欢我今天为你准备的这个故事。它是关于现代滑板作为一种物体的历史。你从来不是一个滑手，但你是一个设计书呆子。这既是一个关于设计的故事，也是一个关于你最不喜欢的朋克亚文化的故事。确实有我不喜欢的朋克亚文化。但我明白你的意思，我非常兴奋。所以当我今天看滑板视频时，我真的很惊讶，每个人骑的所有滑板板面，它们的形状几乎一模一样。
It's called the Popsicle design because the deck is narrow in the middle and rounded off at both ends like a Popsicle stick. And today that's the shape. That is the modern standard issue, capital S skateboard. Now this may seem stupid simple to you, but that basic clean popsicle shape is actually the product of a billion design stages.
它被称为“冰棒”设计，因为板面中间窄，两端圆润，就像一根冰棒棍。今天这就是那种形状。这就是现代标准发行的、大写的S级滑板。现在这在你看来可能简单得愚蠢，但那种基本、干净的冰棒形状实际上是经过了十亿个设计阶段的产物。
Oh, billion, okay. Yeah, like three or four. And each change in the skateboard shape came out of this back and forth and back and forth between, on the one hand, the athletics of this brand new sport, which were evolving fast, and on the other hand, the design of the board itself, which was changing to meet the shifting demands of skateboarding. And this process of constant iteration went on more than a decade. And then I remember it so clearly. In 1989, one skateboard came out that helped set the standard for the deck shape that we
哦，十亿，好吧。是的，大概三四个吧。滑板形状的每一次改变都源于这种来回的博弈，一方面是这项全新运动的竞技性，它在快速演变；另一方面是滑板本身的设计，它在不断改变以满足滑板运动不断变化的需求。这种持续迭代的过程持续了十多年。然后我记得非常清楚。1989年，一款滑板问世，它帮助确立了我们今天所拥有的板面形状标准。
have today. And it totally changed the way that skaters have used their boards ever since. Okay, I am sold. Okay, tell me about this evolution. I cannot wait. Okay, so I want to go back for a second to when the sport of skateboarding really first started popping. That was back in the mid-70s.
它彻底改变了滑手们使用滑板的方式。好吧，我被说服了。好吧，告诉我关于这个演变的过程。我迫不及待了。好的，我想回到滑板运动真正开始流行的时候。那是在70年代中期。
Everyone was skating. Skateboarding is now a new mode of motion here to stay. Skateboards are here, and skateboarding is the hottest new sport to sweep the world. Every hill is a wave of motion. So you have in the late 70s, people are like, skating is big, it's this massive fad, and it's a cool daredevil thing to do. Sean Mortimer is an ex-pro skater and a former skateboard magazine editor. Look at this new dynamic sport,, you can ride up in the air
每个人都在滑板。滑板现在是一种新的运动方式，并将持续存在。滑板来了，滑板运动是席卷全球最热门的新运动。每一座山丘都是一道运动的波浪。所以你在70年代末会看到，人们觉得滑板很火，这是一种巨大的时尚，是一件很酷的敢死队式的事情。肖恩·莫蒂默是一位前职业滑手和前滑板杂志编辑。看看这项新的动态运动，你可以在空中骑行，
and you can be weightless and it's selling that aspect of it. Skateboarding was also being used to sell Pepsi and jeans and RC Cola. So there was a lot of money in skating. First ever world championships, $20,000 per se. This was good money in the 19, I'm just good money now. It was really good money in the 1970s.
你可以处于失重状态，它在兜售这一方面。滑板运动也被用来推销百事可乐、牛仔裤和RC可乐。所以滑板运动里有很多钱。第一届世界锦标赛，奖金2万美元。这在70年代是很好的钱，我只是说现在也是好钱。在70年代这真的是一笔巨款。
If you happen to be in the skateboard industry, your biggest worry is counting your money. The skateboard business is enjoying spectacular prosperity. And Sean says what really helped drive the skating boom was this wave of skateboard park construction. 50 parks opened in California and Florida in less than two years and there was no end in sight. Dentists and all of these people are being sold,
如果你碰巧在滑板行业，你最大的烦恼就是数钱。滑板生意正享受着惊人的繁荣。肖恩说，真正推动滑板热潮的是这波滑板公园建设浪潮。不到两年，加州和佛罗里达州就开了50个公园，而且看不到尽头。牙医和所有这些人都在被推销，
like this is a great investment for your money. You can go build a skate park. Kids love it. They're paying to skate. So pretty much all over the country would be these large concrete skate parks. So what kind of skate park should I be picturing here? Like what do they look like at this time?
就像这是一个很好的投资。你可以去建一个滑板公园。孩子们喜欢它。他们付钱滑板。所以全国各地几乎都有这些大型混凝土滑板公园。那么我应该想象什么样的滑板公园呢？它们当时看起来是什么样的？
Picture gently rolling hills, but made of concrete. And these structures that look kind of like bobsledding tubes, but where skaters could go up and down and up and down. Compared to the skating that you see today, 70s skate park action was gentle. Maybe a little dangerous. I mean, kids were wearing pads and they were wearing helmets because safety first.
想象一下平缓起伏的山丘，但由混凝土制成。还有这些看起来有点像雪橇管的结构，但滑手们可以在里面上下穿梭。与你今天看到的滑板运动相比，70年代的滑板公园动作很温和。也许有点危险。我是说，孩子们戴着护具和头盔，因为安全第一。
But it was kind of like roller skating. It was supposed to be for everybody. And like Sean said, kids loved it. It was super popular and it was super lucrative. And then all of a sudden, whomp, whomp, all of that comes to an end. It had got really popular and then it bottomed out. So it was like a fad like the hula hoop or the pogo stick. And the pogo stick, if you told someone you were,
但这有点像轮滑。它本应是为每个人准备的。就像肖恩说的，孩子们喜欢它。它超级受欢迎，而且超级赚钱。然后突然之间，砰，砰，这一切都结束了。它变得非常流行，然后跌入谷底。所以它就像呼啦圈或弹簧高跷一样的时尚。而弹簧高跷，如果你告诉别人你是，
you know, a professional pogo stick jumper, people would be like, what? The same went for skateboarding. All of the skating kids had grown up and they'd stopped going to skate parks and all of those parks had closed up in just a few years. It followed the track of youth, then you skate and you love it and then you get a car and you get a girlfriend.
你知道，一名职业弹簧高跷跳跃者，人们会说，什么？滑板运动也是如此。所有的滑板小孩都长大了，他们不再去滑板公园，所有这些公园在短短几年内就关闭了。它遵循了青春的轨迹，然后你滑板，你热爱它，然后你有了车，有了女朋友。
So, you know, you had the 70s boom and then it died in the 80s. Okay, so that was the end of this first wave of skateboarding when there was a notion that it would be this mass widespread mainstream sport. Right. But obviously it didn't die completely in the 80s because otherwise, you know, we wouldn't be talking about it right now. Right, right. So it died as this trendy, all the kids are doing it, money-making sensation. But there was a handful of hardcore believers
所以，你知道，你有70年代的繁荣，然后它在80年代消亡了。好吧，所以那是第一波滑板热潮的终结，当时人们认为它会成为一种大众化的主流运动。没错。但显然它在80年代并没有完全消亡，否则，你知道，我们现在就不会谈论它了。对，对。所以它作为一种时髦的、所有孩子都在做、赚钱的轰动效应消亡了。但有一小群硬核信徒
who really wanted this. And these were the ones in the mid 1980s who kept skateboarding alive. You knew in the early 80s, anybody who skated was sort of on that same wavelength because there was no future in it. You weren't getting girls. You weren't popular because you did it.
他们真的想要这个。正是这些人，在80年代中期让滑板运动活了下来。你在80年代初就知道，任何滑板的人都处于同一个频率上，因为这没有前途。你交不到女朋友。你并不因为滑板而受欢迎。
You did it purely because you in it. You weren't getting girls. You weren't popular because you did it. You did it purely because you loved it. At the same time, all the parks are closed. So these kids are really focused on finding and building their own places to skate. Like who needs a skate park? We'll do it ourselves. And ramp skating takes over. And it becomes this whole process of free discovery.
你做这件事纯粹是因为你热爱它。与此同时，所有的公园都关闭了。所以这些孩子真的专注于寻找和建造他们自己的滑板场地。谁需要滑板公园？我们自己动手。坡道滑板接管了一切。它变成了整个自由发现的过程。
They're building half pipes, quarter pipes, lawn tramps. And this is all happening in kids' backyards and on abandoned lots and stuff. That's when they start hopping over fences and riding things that nobody ever imagined before. You have empty pools, you have banks and schools, you have people going to write giant pipes, and that is all innovating, skating the culture
他们建造U型池、四分之一管、草地坡道。这一切都发生在孩子们的后院和废弃的空地上。那时他们开始跳过栅栏，骑行那些以前没人想象过的东西。你有空游泳池，你有银行和学校，你有人们去写巨大的管道，而这一切都在创新，滑板文化
and the product at the same time because there's new demands on all fronts. So this is the first half of the 80s, and it's really different from the skate park era. No more gentle cement curves. These skaters are riding monstrous 30-foot ramps and flying 10 feet above those this is the age of big-air skateboarding okay so the terrain has changed but I was promised to talk about skateboard design and so
和产品同时在进步，因为各方面都有新的需求。所以这是80年代的前半段，它与滑板公园时代真的不同。不再有温和的水泥曲线。这些滑手正在骑行巨大的30英尺坡道，并在这些坡道上方飞行10英尺，这是大跳台滑板的时代。好吧，地形变了，但我被承诺要谈论滑板设计，所以
what kind of decks are these skateboarders riding like to catch that air like if they change to sort of accommodate this new use, this extreme use case. Right, so by this point, towards the mid-1980s, they'd left behind the skateboards from the boom years. Those skateboards were small. They were these teensy things where your feet usually kind of hung over the sides. They were like these little toothpicks. And when you're flying in the air, you need something big to land on.
这些滑手骑的是什么样的板面，比如为了捕捉那种空中动作，如果他们改变以适应这种新的用途，这种极端的使用案例。没错，所以到了80年代中期，他们已经抛弃了繁荣时期的滑板。那些滑板很小。它们是那种小东西，你的脚通常会挂在两边。它们就像那些小牙签。当你飞在空中时，你需要一个大的东西来着陆。
The old boards were just too tiny for all of that. So skateboard start to get longer and they get wider. And skaters actually call these new boards pig boards. At the time there was a regular size, which was like a 10 by 30 board. And that was sort of the standard that had stuck around for a while, very flat with a kick tail. And that kick tail, which of course was at the back of the board, it's where the skateboard turns up kind of at an angle like a lever. Every skateboard deck had one. But even inside of that standard shape, that 30 inch long by 10 inch wide board with a flat
旧的板子对所有这些来说太小了。所以滑板开始变长变宽。滑手们实际上把这些新板子称为“猪板”。当时有一个常规尺寸，大约是10乘30英寸的板子。那是某种已经存在了一段时间的标准，非常平，有一个翘尾。那个翘尾，当然是在板子的后面，它是滑板像杠杆一样向上倾斜的地方。每个滑板板面都有一个。但即使在那个标准形状内，那个30英寸长、10英寸宽、带有平坦
nose and that upturned kick tail, even inside of that template, the design of skateboard decks really varied. So for example, back in the day, if you were to stand on my skateboard, and since you didn't skate, hopefully you wouldn't completely break your neck. And you look down, you'd notice one shape where the board bulged and curved and tapered in certain ways, maybe the nose was rounded off and the tail fanned out. So that'd be one shape.
板头和向上翘起的翘尾的板子，即使在那个模板内，滑板板面的设计也确实各不相同。例如，在过去，如果你站在我的滑板上，既然你不滑板，希望你不会完全摔断脖子。你往下看，你会注意到一种形状，板子在某些地方隆起、弯曲和变细，也许板头是圆的，板尾展开。所以那是一种形状。
And then you stood on my friend's board, you'd see that their board was cut totally differently. This is a completely different shape. So in the mid-80s, boards weren't just getting wider. Board design got super creative and individualized. Boards were coming out in all sorts of weird, specific, sometimes even monstrous and hideous shapes. I mean, there was actually a board called the Nightmare Shape that is infamous for the craziest. Like, like, you're, it had all these like jagged angles on the side
然后你站在我朋友的板子上，你会看到他们的板子切割方式完全不同。这是一个完全不同的形状。所以在80年代中期，板子不仅仅是变宽了。板面设计变得超级有创意和个性化。板子以各种奇怪、具体、有时甚至是怪异和丑陋的形状出现。我是说，实际上有一种叫“噩梦形状”的板子，因为它最疯狂而臭名昭著。就像，就像，你，它侧面有所有这些锯齿状的角度
and people were like, okay, now we're doing stuff that doesn't even, makes no sense. And so what was driving this? Was it, you know, this is what you needed to do fancy tricks on. Was it just the extremeness that was coming up as kind of this cultural force that was blending skateboarding and the punk attitude
人们会说，好吧，现在我们正在做一些甚至没有意义的事情。那么是什么在驱动这个？是，你知道，这是你做花哨技巧所需要的吗？是那种正在兴起的极端性，作为一种将滑板和朋克态度融合在一起的文化力量，
that was pushing boundaries in every way? It's kind of all of that. I mean, some of the boards were ugly just for the sake of being ugly. Just ugly for ugly sake. Yeah, sure. But some of it was functionality. There were skaters who had really specific shapes that were cut to help them skate better.
在各个方面都在突破界限吗？这有点像所有这些。我是说，有些板子丑仅仅是为了丑。仅仅为了丑而丑。是的，当然。但其中一些是功能性的。有些滑手有非常具体的形状，是为了帮助他们滑得更好而切割的。
At least that's what they claimed. And then there was the whole marketing side. A lot of boards were and they still are associated with pro skaters, kind of like basketball shoes. And sometimes you could identify boards just by their shapes, like, oh, that's a Christian Hussoi or that's a Tony Hawk. And of course, the more distinct your pro model design, the more your deck stands out, the more kid can walk into a skate shop point right to your deck stands out, the more a kid can walk into a skate shop, point right to your deck, like, I don't recognize your graphics, but I know your deck shape and I want it. I'm
至少他们是这么声称的。然后还有整个营销方面。很多板子过去是，现在仍然与职业滑手相关联，有点像篮球鞋。有时你可以仅凭形状识别板子，比如，哦，那是克里斯蒂安·霍索伊（Christian Hosoi）的，或者是托尼·霍克（Tony Hawk）的。当然，你的职业模型设计越独特，你的板面就越突出，孩子走进滑板店，直接指向你的板面，就像，我不认识你的图案，但我知道你的板面形状，我想要它。我
telling you, in the mid to late 80s, some of these deck shapes were for skaters as iconic as the Air Jordan Jumpman logo. A big part of your identity as a pro was every board began to look a little different. So it had a it had a bit of character in it. It went from basically a generic uniform 10 by 30 shape to a lot of personality on the side, all different sizes and shapes. But this wild and crazy world of diverse skateboard shapes, it would all soon be over. And that's because the sport itself was changing so fast.
告诉你，在80年代中后期，其中一些板面形状对滑手来说就像Air Jordan的飞人标志一样具有标志性。作为职业选手，你身份的一大部分是每块板子看起来都有一点不同。所以它有一点个性。它从基本上通用的、统一的10乘30形状变成了侧面有很多个性，各种不同的大小和形状。但这个狂野而疯狂的多元滑板形状世界，很快就要结束了。这是因为这项运动本身变化太快了。
And towards the end of the 1980s, a whole new form of skateboarding was blowing up. ["Skateboarding"] Kids start to realize, not only do I not need a skate park, I don't need a half pipe or a home-built ramp or an empty swimming pool or anything. I can just go find a curb or a wheelchair ramp or an embankment behind a school and I can just go nuts and come up with some cool tricks just using my city.
到了80年代末，一种全新的滑板形式正在爆发。“滑板”孩子们开始意识到，我不仅不需要滑板公园，我也不需要U型池、自建坡道、空游泳池或任何东西。我可以随便找个路缘石、轮椅坡道或学校后面的堤岸，我就可以发疯，利用我的城市想出一些很酷的技巧。
This was the beginning of what came to be known as street skating. All of a sudden, anybody, no matter where you were, you could get a skateboard and you could go open your door and go skate. So all of a sudden, if you lived in the city in a cramped area, then you had a skate park right outside your door. So is this still coming from, you know, the Southern California, Dogtown and Z-Boys, you know, peroxide, blonde, floppy-haired kids from the West Coast, or is it spreading out to more of a populace at large?
这就是后来被称为街头滑板的开始。突然之间，任何人，无论你在哪里，你都可以买个滑板，打开门去滑。所以突然之间，如果你住在城市里一个狭窄的区域，那么你家门口就有了一个滑板公园。那么这仍然是来自，你知道，南加州，道格镇和Z-Boys，你知道，西海岸那些过氧化物漂白、金发、头发凌乱的孩子，还是它正在传播到更广泛的大众？
That's a good question. I mean, that's of course where it begins. But then, streetskating as this new thing starts to get pumped out to the world. And that's largely thanks to media. Big skate companies were putting out VHS tapes of streetskating. Skate magazines were featuring streets street skating on their covers. There were even Hollywood movies, you remember gleaming the queue, thrashing, and even Police Academy 4? Well, they all had big street skating scenes. And so now, more and more kids around the globe are seeing street skating.
这是一个好问题。我是说，这当然是它开始的地方。但随后，街头滑板作为一种新事物开始向世界推广。这在很大程度上要归功于媒体。大型滑板公司正在发布街头滑板的VHS录像带。滑板杂志在封面上刊登街头滑板。甚至还有好莱坞电影，你记得《滑板少年》（Gleaming the Cube）、《Thrashing》，甚至《警察学校4》吗？好吧，它们都有大型街头滑板场景。所以现在，全球越来越多的孩子看到了街头滑板。
And this is when I got into skateboarding. And by the way, I have never been nor will I ever be a skinny white kid with peroxide blonde hair and Southern California vibes. Okay, just so you know. Noted. So, okay, quick question. Okay. When street skating was first getting started at this time, what did it actually look like? What were the skaters actually doing? So looking back to that era, as you might imagine, it was pretty humble. There was a lot of imitating ramp moves, like this one trick called a street plant, which was an adaptation of a ramp trick.
这就是我开始接触滑板的时候。顺便说一句，我从来不是，也永远不会是一个留着过氧化物金发、带有南加州氛围的瘦弱白人小孩。好吧，只是让你知道。知道了。所以，好吧，快速问一个问题。好吧。当街头滑板在那个时候刚开始时，它实际上看起来是什么样的？滑手们实际上在做什么？所以回顾那个时代，正如你可能想象的那样，它相当简陋。有很多模仿坡道动作的行为，比如这个叫“街头支撑”（street plant）的技巧，它是坡道技巧的一种改编。
It's sort of a one-handed handstand that you do on a street or on a curb. But the main thing was that for a lot of their tricks, street skaters were kind of just tethered to the ground. And that was mostly because street skating hadn't quite adapted this one core trick called the Olly. And this is where I have to get a little into the mechanics of skating and I'll try to make it quick. This is what radio is made for to describe the mechanics of skating.
这是一种单手倒立，你在街上或路缘石上做。但主要的事情是，对于他们的很多技巧，街头滑手有点被束缚在地面上。这主要是因为街头滑板还没有完全适应这个核心技巧，叫“尖翻”（Ollie）。在这里我必须深入了解滑板的力学，我会尽量快点。这就是广播的用途，描述滑板的力学。
Of skateboard gymnastics. Exactly. It's going to be great. The Ollie is the heart of skating. It is the most fundamental trick. It's actually so essential. I don't think it's actually even considered a trick anymore. Basically, to do an Ollie, you have to snap the tail down with your back foot,
滑板体操的。正是如此。这会很棒。尖翻是滑板的核心。它是最基本的技巧。它实际上太重要了，我不认为它甚至被认为是一个技巧了。基本上，要做一个尖翻，你必须用后脚把板尾向下猛压，
which makes the board pop up in the air at an angle. And as the board rises, you're also jumping, and you're using your front foot to kind of guide the board as it lifts. This is why you need that angle tail to get that first pop in the air. So it takes a little coordination, but the ollie is as central to skateboarding as dribbling is to basketball.
这使得板子以一个角度向上弹起。当板子上升时，你也在跳跃，你用前脚引导板子上升。这就是为什么你需要那个角度的板尾来获得第一次空中弹跳。所以这需要一点协调性，但尖翻对滑板运动的重要性就像运球对篮球一样。
You just, you can't do much without it. So then how does this trick, the ollie, become integral to street skating? The ollie was created on ramps and in pools. And for years, that's mostly where it lived. Ramps gave skaters an extra little bit of jump for their Oli's. It was very hard to do one without a ramp.
你只是，没有它你做不了太多事情。那么这个技巧，尖翻，是如何成为街头滑板不可或缺的一部分的呢？尖翻是在坡道和游泳池里创造出来的。多年来，它主要存在于那里。坡道给了滑手们额外的跳跃力来做尖翻。没有坡道很难做一个。
And that's why the Oli wasn't really part of street skating until sometime in the 1980s, a pro skateboarder named Rodney Mullen figured out how to do an ollie on the flat ground. Rodney made a whole other plane you could do tricks on because before you were just kind of stuck to the ground, so you're doing maneuvers with your wheels on the ground the whole time. Rodney makes it so you can pop into the air.
这就是为什么尖翻直到80年代的某个时候才真正成为街头滑板的一部分，一位名叫罗德尼·穆伦（Rodney Mullen）的职业滑手想出了如何在平地上做尖翻。罗德尼创造了另一个你可以做技巧的平面，因为之前你只是被困在地面上，所以你一直在地面上用轮子做动作。罗德尼让你可以弹跳到空中。
There was evolving a new kind of skateboarding where guys were taking it to the streets. Here's Rodney Mullen giving a TED Talk in 2012, where he describes how skateboarders in the late 1980s were adapting his innovation. And they were using that ollie like I showed you. They were using it to get up on the stuff, like bleachers and handrails and over stairwells and all kinds of cool stuff So it was evolving upwards. In fact when someone tells you they're a skater today They pretty much mean a street skater because It seems so basic now that most skaters today probably don't even think about it
一种新的滑板运动正在演变，人们把它带到了街头。这是罗德尼·穆伦在2012年的TED演讲，他描述了80年代末的滑手们是如何适应他的创新的。他们正在使用我向你展示的那种尖翻。他们用它来登上东西，比如看台和扶手，越过楼梯井和各种很酷的东西。所以它在向上演变。事实上，当今天有人告诉你他们是滑手时，他们基本上指的是街头滑手，因为现在这看起来太基础了，以至于今天大多数滑手可能甚至不会去想它，
but Mullen helped street skaters figure out how to jump up into the air, high into the air, and onto things and over things. Mullen also infused street skating with all these really sophisticated, complex tricks that he'd invented. Flipping and spinning and jumping in the air on the board in a million different ways, mostly just using your feet. Okay, so this is inspiring a whole new approach to skateboarding. The athletics of this board have changed again. So what does this mean for the shape
但穆伦帮助街头滑手弄清楚了如何跳到空中，跳得很高，跳到东西上，越过东西。穆伦还向街头滑板注入了所有这些他发明的非常复杂、精巧的技巧。在板上以一百万种不同的方式翻转、旋转和跳跃，主要只是用你的脚。好吧，所以这激发了一种全新的滑板方法。这个板子的竞技性再次改变了。那么这对滑板本身的形状意味着什么
of skateboards themselves? Like at this point, how did they evolve thanks to these innovations? Okay, so a couple of things. First of all, street skaters didn't need those giant boards anymore. They weren't concerned with sticking the landing after flying 100 feet in the air.
呢？比如在这一点上，多亏了这些创新，它们是如何演变的？好吧，所以有几件事。首先，街头滑手不再需要那些巨大的板子了。他们不关心在空中飞行100英尺后着陆。
For them, the ollie is the main thing. So what they really needed was a better tail that was more precisely angled so that you could get that good snap and lift. And because the street tricks were getting more sophisticated and technical with all the spinning and the flipping, the board shape needed to be way less fussy and cumbersome. It needed to be less weird and more streamlined and smooth.
对他们来说，尖翻是主要的事情。所以他们真正需要的是一个更好的板尾，角度更精确，这样你才能获得那种好的弹跳和提升。而且因为街头技巧随着所有的旋转和翻转变得越来越复杂和技术化，板子形状需要变得不那么挑剔和笨重。它需要变得不那么奇怪，更流线型、更平滑。
The skateboard was evolving fast from a big clunky piece of self-expression to this elegant tool. So now, it's the end of the 80s, and there's been all these skateboard design shifts that have happened over the previous decade, decade and a half. And this is when it all culminates in a single skateboard model
滑板正在从一个巨大的、笨拙的自我表达工具快速演变成一个优雅的工具。所以现在，是80年代末了，在过去十年、十几年里发生了所有这些滑板设计转变。而这时，这一切都汇聚在一个单一的滑板模型中，
that arrives and becomes the template for the skate decks that we know today. There were three guys who really made this happen. First, there was this teenager from Edison, New Jersey decks that we know today. There were three guys who really made this happen. First, there was this teenager from Edison, New Jersey who comes on the scene. His name is Mike Valely. Fellow 80s skateheads chill. I know that we grew up calling him Valely.
它到来并成为我们今天所知的滑板板面的模板。有三个人真正促成了这一点。首先，有一个来自新泽西州爱迪生的青少年，我们今天所知的板面。有三个人真正促成了这一点。首先，有一个来自新泽西州爱迪生的青少年出现在现场。他的名字叫迈克·瓦莱利（Mike Vallely）。80年代的滑板迷们冷静点。我知道我们从小叫他瓦莱利。
But Valely, Hello, my name is Mike Valely, is how he says his last name. Mike was huge back then. He embodied that shift from so-cal surfer kid vibes to this grittier, more salt-of-the-earth East Coast energy. I started skating in the streets. That was the most exciting aspect of discovering skateboarding.
但瓦莱利，你好，我的名字是迈克·瓦莱利，他是这样说他的姓氏的。迈克当时非常出名。他体现了从南加州冲浪小孩氛围到这种更坚韧、更脚踏实地的东海岸能量的转变。我开始在街头滑板。那是发现滑板运动最令人兴奋的方面。
Here's Mike in a documentary about his career. You didn't need a swimming pool. You didn't need to be in California under some palm tree. You could do that in Edison, New Jersey. He was this skinny, ratty kid who was obsessed with skating. And he shaved his head, which wasn't common at the time. So he not only did he have the skill set, but you looked at him and you're like,
这是迈克在一部关于他职业生涯的纪录片中说的话。你不需要游泳池。你不需要在加州某棵棕榈树下。你可以在新泽西州的爱迪生做到这一点。他是一个瘦弱、邋遢、痴迷于滑板的孩子。他剃了光头，这在当时并不常见。所以他不仅拥有技能，而且你看着他，你会觉得，
oh, he's not like any other skater. So he represented the new generation of what skating could be. And Valilee had other skaters around him who were pushing him to try new things. At the time, he skated for a company called World Industries, which was run by some very young skaters. World Industries was aggressive at taking on
哦，他不像任何其他滑手。所以他代表了滑板运动可能成为的新一代。瓦莱利周围有其他滑手在推动他尝试新事物。当时，他为一家叫World Industries的公司滑板，该公司由一些非常年轻的滑手经营。World Industries在对抗
all the dinosaur companies like Palo Peralta and Santa Cruz, and they did it by poaching their star skaters and taking shots at them in their ads, just grimy stuff. And they were rubbing everyone the wrong way, except skaters. We loved world industries. This was the new energy Roman. It was edgy. And their pros were sick, including Mike Valilly. He was amazing. So how did that world industry sort of aggro punk attitude, like did that affect the skating? Yes. So the owner of World Industries was this guy named Steve Rocco, and he was really pushing
所有像Palo Peralta和Santa Cruz这样的恐龙公司时非常激进，他们通过挖走他们的明星滑手并在广告中攻击他们来做到这一点，简直是肮脏的手段。他们让每个人都不爽，除了滑手。我们喜欢World Industries。这是新的能量，罗曼。它很前卫。他们的职业选手很厉害，包括迈克·瓦莱利。他太棒了。那么那种World Industries的激进朋克态度，它影响了滑板运动吗？是的。所以World Industries的老板是一个叫史蒂夫·罗科（Steve Rocco）的人，他真的在推动
Mike to try new things when it came to the way that Mike skated. Mike talked about this moment a few years ago on a skateboarding podcast called The Nine Club. It starts with Steve Rocco believing in, you know, switch stance skating or skating in both directions as a future of skateboarding very early on. Okay, switch stance skating. What is it?
迈克尝试迈克滑板方式的新事物。迈克几年前在一个叫《The Nine Club》的滑板播客上谈到了这个时刻。它始于史蒂夫·罗科相信，你知道，反脚滑板（switch stance skating）或双向滑板是滑板运动的未来，非常早。好吧，反脚滑板。它是什么？
Can you explain it a little more? At this point, most skaters could only ride with their right or their left foot forward. And that's called directional skating. Being able to do both, that's switch stance skateboarding. It's like being able to ride with your left hand just as well as your right hand. If you could ride switch,
你能多解释一下吗？在这一点上，大多数滑手只能用右脚或左脚向前滑行。这被称为定向滑板。能够两者兼顾，那就是反脚滑板。就像能够用左手和右手一样好地骑行。如果你能反脚滑行，
you could really expand your bag of tricks. And Mike wasn't really into switch skating. And I don't really blame him to be honest. Skating that way is very hard to do and That's partly because of the way that boards were shaped Yes, they were getting a little smaller and they were also more streamlined than those massive pig boards of old But they still had a lot of the traits of the old-school skate decks like the flat noses in the front and the kick tails in the back. Those boards just weren't built for switch skating.
你真的可以扩展你的技巧包。迈克对反脚滑板并不太感兴趣。老实说，我并不怪他。那样滑板很难做到，这部分是因为板子的形状。是的，它们变得有点小了，而且比那些旧的巨大的猪板更流线型。但它们仍然有很多老派滑板板面的特征，比如前面的平坦板头和后面的翘尾。那些板子根本不是为反脚滑板建造的。
But despite Mike being kind of lukewarm about all this, Rocco, it probably won't surprise you, would not let it go. And he saw an opportunity for world industries to go all in on this idea of switch stand skating as the future of skateboarding. And he decided, let's drop a pro model skateboard design that'll really push the sport and of course his own brand forward. And Mike's name was big enough to get real attention
但尽管迈克对这一切有点不冷不热，罗科，这可能不会让你感到惊讶，他不会放手。他看到了World Industries全力投入反脚滑板作为滑板运动未来的机会。他决定，让我们发布一款职业模型滑板设计，它将真正推动这项运动，当然还有他自己的品牌向前发展。迈克的名字足够大，可以引起真正的关注，
and make kids believe in something that looked really different. Right, right. So Rocco was like a dog with a bone when it comes to this idea of switch skating because he's got this thing that he wants to make and sell. So, what did they come up with to sort of push this idea of switch skating out in the world? So, Rodney Mullin was also skating and he was designing skateboards for world industries.
并让孩子们相信看起来非常不同的东西。对，对。所以罗科在这个反脚滑板的想法上就像狗咬骨头一样，因为他有这个他想制造和销售的东西。所以，他们想出了什么来推动这个反脚滑板的想法在世界上流行？所以，罗德尼·穆伦也在滑板，他正在为World Industries设计滑板。
He kind of took his expertise as this highly technical skater and he merged that with his knowledge of other skateboard prototypes that were out there. And then in 1989, our star is bored. Rodney created a pro-model skateboard from Mike Valoli that has come to be known as the barnyard. So I'll get to that name in a second, but there are two remarkable things about this deck.
他把他作为一名高技术滑手的专业知识与他对其他现有滑板原型的知识融合在一起。然后在1989年，我们的明星板子诞生了。罗德尼为迈克·瓦莱利创造了一款职业模型滑板，后来被称为“谷仓”（Barnyard）。所以我一会儿会讲到那个名字，但这个板面有两件非凡的事情。
First of all, the shape. Instead of that traditional design with a flat nose in the front and an upturned kick tail in the back, this skateboard had two tails, one on each end. No more nose, the barnyard had two kick tails, which is a design style called the double kick. And it was the prototype for the skateboards that we have today. It was such a large leap, and it kind of leapfrogged it over these incremental steps to get there,
首先，形状。它没有那种前面有平坦板头、后面有向上翘起的翘尾的传统设计，这个滑板有两个板尾，每一端一个。不再有板头，谷仓板有两个翘尾，这是一种被称为“双翘”（double kick）的设计风格。它是我们今天所拥有的滑板的原型。这是一个如此巨大的飞跃，它有点跨越了达到这一点的渐进步骤，
that it took a while when you held it in your hand because you were just so used to going, here is sort of the silhouette of a skateboard, you know, it tapers here, it's directional. And then you had this thing that to a certain extent looked like an uncut piece of wood. I have to say right quick, Roman, just as an aside that the shape of the barnyard, it was kind of a beast. Like it was cut like a big rectangular slab of laminated
以至于当你把它拿在手里时需要一段时间，因为你太习惯于说，这是滑板的轮廓，你知道，它在这里变细，它是定向的。然后你有这个东西，在某种程度上看起来像一块未切割的木头。我必须快速说一下，罗曼，顺便提一下，谷仓板的形状，它有点像个野兽。它被切割得像一块巨大的长方形层压木板，
wood with these slightly rounded edges and both ends were turned up at an angle. No one had ever really seen a pro model like this before. Definitely not Mike Valoli. And when Rodney brings it to Mike and he shows it to him, he's all proud like, hey bud, here's your new pro model skateboard. What do you think?
边缘略圆，两端都向上翘起一个角度。以前没人真正见过这样的职业模型。迈克·瓦莱利绝对没有。当罗德尼把它带给迈克并展示给他看时，他很自豪，就像，嘿伙计，这是你的新职业模型滑板。你觉得怎么样？
And I go, I don't know dude, it's hideous. He goes, just try it, just try it. And I go, I don't know, dude, it's hideous. He goes, just try it. Just try it. So I go in, I skate it. Yeah. And it functions. And I dig it. And I skate really well on it. And I go, okay, let's do it. And man, there was no turning back. The board just went. It's the best selling board I've ever had. When Valelie's barnyard skate deck came out in 1989, it was the first ever pro model double kick board. And it was the first double kick that was mass produced. And what was it that drew skaters to the barnyard?
我说，我不知道伙计，它太丑了。他说，试一下，试一下。我说，我不知道，伙计，它太丑了。他说，试一下。试一下。所以我进去了，我滑了它。是的。它起作用了。我喜欢它。我在上面滑得非常好。我说，好吧，我们做吧。伙计，没有回头路了。板子就是这样。这是我卖得最好的板子。当瓦莱利的谷仓滑板板面在1989年问世时，它是第一款职业模型双翘板。它是第一款大规模生产的双翘板。是什么吸引滑手们去买谷仓板？
What made the arrival of this board so explosive? Like such a huge deal. So first of all, it was Mike Valli's star power. Plus, there was that innovative new shape. I mean, skaters immediately saw endless possibilities. And then on top of all of that, it had these wild, unforgettable graphics. So much of skateboard art today
是什么让这款板子的到来如此具有爆炸性？就像一件大事。所以首先，它是迈克·瓦莱利的明星力量。加上那种创新的新形状。我是说，滑手们立刻看到了无限的可能性。然后除此之外，它还有这些狂野、令人难忘的图案。今天如此多的滑板艺术
can be traced back to the barnyard. Just like the deck shape Herald did something new, so did the barnyard's artwork. That's because up until the barnyard, a lot of skateboard graphics had been like, oh, that's a cool design, like a hand that's also a screaming face that's got its tongue sticking out.
都可以追溯到谷仓板。就像板面形状预示了新事物一样，谷仓板的艺术作品也是如此。这是因为在谷仓板之前，很多滑板图案一直是，哦，那是一个很酷的设计，比如一只手也是一张尖叫的脸，舌头伸出来。
I know that one. Or you might see these grotesque, kind of gothy style graphics, like heavy metal skulls or bulging eyeballs or flame shooting every which way. This was nothing super deep. But Valérie's graphics were totally different. They depict a barnyard scene with a bunch of happy, fluorescent farm animals.
我知道那个。或者你可能会看到这些怪诞的、哥特风格的图案，比如重金属头骨或凸出的眼球或向四面八方喷射的火焰。这没什么特别深刻的。但瓦莱利的图案完全不同。它们描绘了一个谷仓场景，里面有一群快乐的、荧光的农场动物。
There's a bright yellow rooster, a glowing magenta pig, a duck with a boombox. It's a party. And all those bright happy animals on Mike's board, that art was a nod to Mike's avid vegetarianism. In fact, one part of the artwork actually even says, please don't eat my friends. So instead of snakes or gargoyles or monsters, this was social commentary. This was a political cartoon on the bottom of a skateboard.
有一只亮黄色的公鸡，一只发光的洋红色猪，一只带着收音机的鸭子。这是一个派对。迈克板子上所有那些明亮快乐的动物，那艺术是对迈克热衷素食主义的致敬。事实上，艺术作品的一部分甚至写着，请不要吃我的朋友。所以不是蛇或石像鬼或怪物，这是社会评论。这是滑板底部的一幅政治漫画。
And when you look at the board and you look at the colors and you look at the lines and the energy of it, is no, there'd been no graphic. No graphic like this previously. This was the beginning of a different era in skateboard graphics. The barnyard deck had been the catalyst for this whole shift. From that point, skateboard art really started to change. Graphics got more ironic, more irreverent, sometimes more political.
当你看着板子，看着颜色，看着线条和它的能量时，没有，以前没有这样的图案。这是滑板图案不同时代的开始。谷仓板面是整个转变的催化剂。从那时起，滑板艺术真的开始改变了。图案变得更讽刺、更不敬，有时更政治化。
So you can see why so many people, us skaters, the industry, everybody, we were all totally sucked in. They had this very strong personality coming through on a very strong graphic in a very strong shape of a board. And so many people just wanted to be like Mike Valeli. They didn't want to be like Michael Jordan skaters. They wanted to be like Mike Laylee. They didn't want to be like Michael Jordan skaters. They wanted to be like like the Laylee. So in all of these different ways, Mike and his barnyard skateboard, they help kick in
所以你可以看出为什么这么多人，我们滑手，行业，每个人，我们都被完全吸引了。他们在一个非常强烈的板子形状上有一种非常强烈的个性，通过一个非常强烈的图案表现出来。而且很多人只是想成为迈克·瓦莱利。他们不想成为迈克尔·乔丹式的滑手。他们想成为像瓦莱利那样的人。所以通过所有这些不同的方式，迈克和他的谷仓滑板，他们帮助踢开了
the door and really change our sense of what a skater could look like, what skateboard art could be. And most important, what the board itself could help you do. The barnyard announced that there was a new era of skating and that was a really bold announcement. It was the extreme that came into the industry. So this sounds like a perfect moment where there's this business culture around, you know, innovation. There's like new stars with different attitudes all coming together to sort of create this thing and push everything forward. and push everything forward. Yes, and the barnyard also supercharged
大门，真正改变了我们对滑手可能看起来是什么样、滑板艺术可能是什么样的感觉。最重要的是，板子本身能帮你做什么。谷仓板宣布了一个新的滑板时代，这是一个非常大胆的声明。它是进入行业的极端。所以这听起来像是一个完美的时刻，有一种围绕着，你知道，创新的商业文化。有新的明星带着不同的态度，所有这些都汇聚在一起，创造了这个东西并推动一切向前发展。
this shift in the athleticism of the sport. Right. Most skateboarders had learned to do tricks like the Oli with only their left or their right foot in the back. Now, with two tails, maybe you could learn with both feet. And that's just the beginning, right? And anyway, forwards and backwards kind of become meaningless with a skateboard like this.
是的，谷仓板也给这项运动的竞技性带来了巨大的推动。对。大多数滑手学会做像尖翻这样的技巧时，只有左脚或右脚在后面。现在，有了两个板尾，也许你可以用双脚学习。这只是开始，对吧？无论如何，有了这样的滑板，向前和向后变得毫无意义。
So you're really becoming kind of, what's the foot version of ambidextrous, ambidextrous? Yes, maybe. By the time you get to the barnyard, that is one that's truly saying you can skate both ways. You can ollie on your nose instead of just a regular ollie on your tail. All of these tricks became
所以你真的变得有点，什么是双手的脚的版本，双脚灵巧？是的，也许。当你拿到谷仓板时，那是一个真正说明你可以双向滑板的板子。你可以在板头上做尖翻，而不是仅仅在板尾做常规尖翻。所有这些技巧都变成了
different directions. You know, they always talk about the difference with humans is the development of tools and what that does to your brain. If you think of it that way, then you think of a double kick inspiring a skater's brain in a different way. in a different way. So, Roman, I remember a plain as day when I first saw the barnyard in real life. It was back in 1989. I was at my favorite skate spot, which was this place in Silver Spring, Maryland called the Armory. Today, it's a parking garage, but the old heads know we used to shred that place.
不同的方向。你知道，他们总是谈论人类的区别在于工具的发展以及这对你的大脑有什么影响。如果你这样想，那么你就会认为双翘板以一种不同的方式激发了滑手的大脑。所以，罗曼，我清楚地记得我第一次在现实生活中看到谷仓板的时候。那是在1989年。我在我最喜欢的滑板点，那是马里兰州银泉市一个叫“军械库”（Armory）的地方。今天，它是一个停车场，但老手们知道我们过去常在那里狂滑。
And then one day this kid named Jack, who was already an excellent skater, he showed up with this new board and it blew everyone's mind. I mean, we were all like, what the hell is that? That Jack is riding. It looked like something from the woodshop scrap pile. And then I remember Jack riding it and he killed it. Like he was doing old tricks in new ways, new tricks in crazy ways. It just upped his game amazingly. I was 13 or 14 at the time.
然后有一天，这个叫杰克的孩子，他已经是一名出色的滑手，他带着这个新板子出现了，它让所有人都大吃一惊。我是说，我们都像，杰克骑的是什么鬼东西？它看起来像木工废料堆里的东西。然后我记得杰克骑着它，他表现得太棒了。他以新的方式做旧技巧，以疯狂的方式做新技巧。它真的让他的水平惊人地提高了。我当时13或14岁。
And of course I had no idea that I was basically looking at a huge design shift that was going to help reshape the sport and the design of decks for the next three and a half decades. Yeah, that's amazing. Okay, so you were 13 or 14 when you first saw the barnyard and now it's 30 something years later. Something, something years later. And so was this the final step before we get to that popsicle shape that you described in the beginning, like the standard skateboard design that you see everywhere today? Like, did the barnyard really set the agenda from here on out or was there more variation to come?
当然，我当时根本不知道，我所看到的基本上是一个巨大的设计转变，它将在接下来的三十五年里重塑这项运动以及滑板的设计。是的，这太神奇了。好吧，你第一次看到Barnyard滑板时才13或14岁，现在已经是30多年后了。三十多年后。那么，这是否就是我们最终得到你开头所描述的那种“冰棒”形状滑板之前的最后一步，也就是今天随处可见的标准滑板设计？Barnyard滑板是否真的从那时起就定下了基调，还是说未来还会有更多的变化？
So before the barnyard, skateboards came in all sorts of shapes and sizes. Okay, but then the barnyard drops and what had been this soft malleable clay of skateboard design really starts to stiffen and become more fixed. The barnyard became a prototype which designers did still fuzz with, rounding out the tail and the nose, and making the board a little skinnier. So they made minor adjustments incrementally until you get what you get now, which is the popsicle, which is really, you could say the popsicle is the offspring of the double kick,
在Barnyard滑板出现之前，滑板有各种各样的形状和尺寸。好吧，但后来Barnyard滑板问世了，原本那种柔软、可塑的滑板设计开始变得僵硬和固定。Barnyard滑板成为了一个原型，设计师们仍然会对其进行修补，把尾部和头部磨圆，让板身变得更窄一些。所以他们进行了细微的渐进式调整，直到得到现在的样子，也就是“冰棒”滑板，你可以说“冰棒”滑板是双翘滑板的后代，
and that is the staple. Basically speaking, most people ride Popsicles. So the double kick was sort of the parent of what we have now. It really is just a pure design story. Like the needs are pushing the tool. The tool is pushing what people can do. And this is feeding back into what people create. It's so interesting. And then obviously the big leap is you take this thing out and you put a second kicktail
而那才是主流。基本上，大多数人都骑“冰棒”滑板。所以双翘滑板算是我们现在所用滑板的鼻祖。这确实是一个纯粹的设计故事。需求在推动工具的发展。工具也在推动人们能做的事情。而这又反过来影响了人们的创造。这太有趣了。显然，最大的飞跃就是你带着这个东西出去，然后给它加上第二个翘尾，
on it, you know. But it does make me wonder if other things are possible. Like is there something out there on the horizon that could change skateboarding again in a big way, like, you know, for another 35 years? You know, actually, I talked to someone about this exact idea. Her name is Betsy Gordon, and she's a project manager at the Smithsonian, where she's co-edited a book and done an exhibition on skateboarding. And Betsy brought up that skating right now is being influenced by these huge international
你知道的。但这确实让我好奇是否还有其他可能。比如，地平线上是否有什么东西能再次以巨大的方式改变滑板运动，就像接下来的35年那样？其实，我和某人谈过这个确切的想法。她叫贝齐·戈登，是史密森尼学会的项目经理，她曾共同编辑过一本书并举办过关于滑板的展览。贝齐提到，现在的滑板运动正受到像X Games和奥运会这样大型国际赛事的影响。
competitions like the X Games and the Olympics. And she said that might actually shape the future of skateboard design. So when you're not just skating with your friends outside of the DMV downtown, but you're in these intense contests that demand super precise riding. That's one way now to be a skater, to compete in this incredibly high, trick-oriented, performance-oriented level. And will we see something completely different? I think of like those ships now that sail in the America's Cup.
她说这实际上可能会塑造滑板设计的未来。所以，当你不仅仅是在DMV市中心外和朋友们滑板，而是参加这些要求超精准骑行的激烈比赛时。这现在成为了滑手的一种方式，即在极高、以技巧为导向、以表现为导向的水平上进行竞争。我们会看到完全不同的东西吗？我想到了现在参加美洲杯帆船赛的那些船。
They look like a boat. I mean, you know what I mean? You're like, what the? Because you're talking about wind and speed and velocity is completely changing. It doesn't get anything like a boat. So I wonder as performance starts driving skating, are we going to see a very different skateboard? I wonder. Oh, you could totally imagine some performance style skateboard that is as different from a regular skateboard as an America's Cup sailboat is to a sailboat, you know, that goes up like a hundred feet
它们看起来像船。我的意思是，你明白我的意思吗？你会想，什么鬼？因为你在谈论风、速度和速率，一切都在彻底改变。它看起来一点也不像船。所以我很好奇，随着表现开始驱动滑板运动，我们会看到一种非常不同的滑板吗？我很好奇。哦，你完全可以想象出某种表现风格的滑板，它与普通滑板的区别就像美洲杯帆船与普通帆船的区别一样，你知道，如果你上坡或者类似的东西，它能飞到一百英尺高。
in the air if you go up a ramp or something like this. I never really thought about this. I mean, I've always sort of enjoyed the art in this sort of, in the athleticism of skateboarding from afar as we established earlier. But it really is a good object to think about design as a whole. Like I'm really happy about this. So this is fun. Thank you. You are welcome. Every skater dreams of a great skate spot. Philadelphia had one for decades. It was called Love Park and it was perfect until the city tore it down. That story after the break.
我从来没想过这个问题。我的意思是，正如我们之前所确定的，我一直从远处欣赏滑板运动中的艺术和运动能力。但它确实是一个思考整体设计的好对象。我对此感到非常高兴。这很有趣。谢谢你。不客气。每个滑手都梦想着一个很棒的滑板场地。费城几十年来一直有一个。它叫Love Park，它很完美，直到城市把它拆除。休息后讲述那个故事。
This is a 99% of visible story from 11 years ago if you can believe that. It seemed appropriate to revisit it. Enjoy. Oh, God! Thank you, thank you, thank you! My whole damn life has been worth it, just for this moment. So I was once walking the city with my friend Kathleen, who is an environmental scientist, and she was pointing out the spray-painted markings of letters and arrows that you see everywhere on the street. The markings indicate where utility lines are running underground so they're not damaged
这是一个11年前的99%不可见的故事，如果你能相信的话。重温它似乎很合适。享受吧。天哪！谢谢，谢谢，谢谢！我这一辈子都值了，就为了这一刻。所以有一次我和我的朋友凯瑟琳在城里散步，她是一位环境科学家，她指出了你在街上随处可见的喷漆字母和箭头标记。这些标记指示地下公用设施线路的走向，以免它们被施工损坏。
by construction. And it turns out they're color-coded by the American Public Works Association. Red spray paint means electrical power lines and yellow is natural gas. And I'm looking this up now on Wikipedia because I don't remember all the details. Green means sewage and drainage lines. So public works people and construction crews have their own lo-fi augmented reality scribbled right on the street, like a giant map in plain sight. It's a different way to see the city. But it's not just utility workers. The city also reads
结果发现它们是根据美国公共工程协会的颜色编码的。红色喷漆代表电力线，黄色代表天然气。我现在正在维基百科上查这个，因为我不记得所有细节了。绿色代表污水和排水管道。所以公共工程人员和施工队在街上就有他们自己的低保真增强现实涂鸦，就像一张显而易见的巨大地图。这是一种看待城市的不同方式。但不仅仅是公用事业工人。城市也会根据你的知识、经验，或者你是否恰好站在一块滚动的木板上而有不同的解读。
differently depending on your knowledge, your experience, or if you happen to be standing on a rolling plank of wood. I've been lucky enough to go to these amazing places like Taiwan or LA, but I only ever get to see like the weird places that skaters go to, like industrial parks or some handrail in the middle of a school somewhere. That's our guide today, skateboard photographer and radio reporter, Andrew Norton. My friend Ariel and I are skating in downtown Toronto, kind of carving through the big, empty corporate plazas.
我有幸去过台湾或洛杉矶这些令人惊叹的地方，但我只能看到滑手们去的那些奇怪的地方，比如工业园区或学校中间的某个扶手。这就是我们今天的向导，滑板摄影师兼电台记者安德鲁·诺顿。我和我的朋友阿里尔正在多伦多市中心滑板，在空旷的企业广场中穿梭。
It's hard with a backpack. Yeah, I'll give you one of these though. To a skateboarder, the city looks different. Something I definitely always do is is look for opportunities to skateboard. I can't help myself. We compulsively look for things like ledges or curb cuts, mundane stuff that people walk right past.
背着背包很难。是的，但我会给你一个这个。对于滑手来说，城市看起来是不一样的。我绝对总是做的一件事就是寻找滑板的机会。我无法控制自己。我们强迫性地寻找像壁架或路缘斜坡这样的东西，那些人们直接走过的平凡事物。
But to a skateboarder, even a pole that's been bent by a car is a thing to skate. So you're always on the hunt. Like, I'll make my wife stop the car if I see something new. Dude, I even like, I even when I'm watching movies, we'll be looking for spots. Ha ha ha, you look for spots in movies? Whoa, Andrew.
但对滑手来说，即使是被汽车撞弯的杆子也是可以滑的东西。所以你总是在寻找。比如，如果我看到什么新东西，我会让我的妻子停车。伙计，我甚至，我甚至在看电影时也会寻找场地。哈哈，你在电影里找场地？哇，安德鲁。
Like I've watched The Simpsons and I'm like, you could skate that HUBBA. You know what? I guess I do that too. Wait, what's a HUBBA? A HUBBA is what skaters call a ledge that runs down a flight of stairs parallel to the stairs. And it's named after a famous spot in San Francisco
就像我看《辛普森一家》时，我会想，你可以滑那个HUBBA。你知道吗？我想我也那样做。等等，什么是HUBBA？HUBBA是滑手们对那种沿着楼梯平行延伸的壁架的称呼。它以旧金山一个著名的场地命名，
called HUBBA hideout. HUBBA is slang for crack. So I guess people used to hang out there, used to gather there to smoke crack. It's particularly skateboard worthy. Yeah, because it's this perfect ledge that runs parallel down the flight of stairs. I mean, ask any skater, go to any skate park.
叫HUBBA hideout。HUBBA是快克毒品的俚语。所以我猜人们过去常在那里闲逛，聚在那里吸食快克。它特别适合滑板。是的，因为它是一个完美的壁架，沿着楼梯平行延伸。我的意思是，问任何一个滑手，去任何一个滑板公园。
You know, every skater will know what a Huba is. And that is how I'm going to exclusively refer to them from now on. I'm always looking for things like that. Black wax kicked on a ledge or wheel marks on a wall. These are little bread crumb trails left by my people. And once you start following these trails, they'll lead you to a turf war between the city and the skaters. Oh, this spot here. Have you rescaded these? This has long been known as a spot to meet up. And more recently, they put some stoppers on it to prevent people from skating.
你知道，每个滑手都会知道什么是HUBBA。从现在开始，我将专门这样称呼它们。我总是寻找这样的东西。壁架上的黑色蜡或墙上的轮印。这些是我的人留下的面包屑痕迹。一旦你开始跟随这些痕迹，它们就会把你引向城市和滑手之间的地盘争夺战。哦，这个地方。你重新滑过这些吗？这里长期以来一直被称为聚会点。最近，他们安装了一些挡块来阻止人们滑板。
So a skate stopper is anything that someone might add to something we'd want a skateboard on to stop us from skateboarding on it. So in this case, on these long, kind of S-shaped granite benches that we're looking at, they put strips of granite kind of running the width of the bench so that we can't ride along the top of it. Normally people would be sliding on this and then hit this or grinding on this and then hit, come to a stop against these. I imagine most people don't know what they're there for.
所以滑板挡块是任何人可能添加到我们想要滑板的地方，以阻止我们在上面滑板的东西。所以在这个案例中，在我们正在看的这些长长的、S形的花岗岩长椅上，他们安装了横跨长椅宽度的花岗岩条，这样我们就不能沿着它的顶部滑行。通常人们会在上面滑动，然后撞到这个，或者在上面研磨，然后撞到这些东西并停下来。我想大多数人不知道它们是干什么用的。
So as skateboarders I think we're hyper-s sensitive and very aware of these small things that get added. Well one of the the most traditional type of thing you'll see will be some kind of a metal peg or raised metal attachment that is either built into a wall or attached to a wall afterwards and what that does is it creates a discontinuous edge. Tony Bricoli is an architect from Philadelphia. He's fascinated with how skaters interact with the city. And though he's not a skateboarder himself, Tony's always kept tabs on the types of anti skating measures the city can deploy.
所以作为滑手，我认为我们对这些被添加的小东西非常敏感和警觉。嗯，你会看到的最传统的东西之一是某种金属钉或凸起的金属附件，它要么内置在墙里，要么事后安装在墙上，它的作用是创造一个不连续的边缘。托尼·布里科利是一位来自费城的建筑师。他着迷于滑手如何与城市互动。虽然他自己不是滑手，但托尼一直关注城市可以部署的各种反滑板措施。
And then it gets more extreme and more ridiculous where, you know, there are companies that sell things that look like metal seashells and metal crabs that I guess for some reason that's meant to be more aesthetically pleasing, I don't know. Those aesthetically pleasing skate stoppers are all around the Marquedero in San Francisco. To Tony, the reason why modern cities are so perfect for skateboarding goes back to a French dude named Lake Corbusier. Tony Bricale wrote an essay called Thanks, Le Corbusier, from the skateboarders. In it, he contends that Le Corbusier,
然后它变得更加极端和荒谬，你知道，有些公司销售看起来像金属贝壳和金属螃蟹的东西，我猜出于某种原因，那意味着更美观，我不知道。那些美观的滑板挡块遍布旧金山的Marquedero。对托尼来说，现代城市之所以如此适合滑板，要追溯到一个叫勒·柯布西耶的法国人。托尼·布里卡莱写了一篇名为《感谢勒·柯布西耶，来自滑手们》的文章。在文中，他认为勒·柯布西耶，
as the platonic ideal of the modernist architect with his cool glasses and love of concrete, is the patron saint of skateboarders. Modernists were the ones that reinterpreted a bench in a park as a slab of granite. Reinterpreted, you know, kind of flowing landscapes, grassy areas as these kind of paved open plaza spaces. And it just turned out that wide open space with nice granite ledges at the edge made
作为现代主义建筑师的柏拉图式理想，戴着酷炫的眼镜，热爱混凝土，是滑手们的守护神。现代主义者是那些将公园里的长椅重新诠释为花岗岩板的人。重新诠释了，你知道，那种流动的景观、草地，作为这种铺设好的开放广场空间。结果证明，边缘有漂亮花岗岩壁架的宽阔开放空间，
really good skateboarding space. And who would have known? The prime example of modernist landscape architecture that's inadvertently perfect for skateboarding is Philadelphia's Love Park. Its real name is JFK Plaza, but it's called Love Park after Robert Indiana's giant love statue with that slanted O that was put there for the United States by Centennial. In the center of Philadelphia is City Hall. And if you draw a line from City Hall to the Art Museum, there's
是非常好的滑板空间。谁会想到呢？现代主义景观建筑的典型例子，无意中非常适合滑板，就是费城的Love Park。它的真名是JFK广场，但它被称为Love Park，是以罗伯特·印第安纳的巨大“爱”雕塑命名的，那个雕塑带有倾斜的O，是为美国建国两百周年而放置在那里的。费城市中心是市政厅。如果你从市政厅画一条线到艺术博物馆，有一条
a diagonal boulevard that connects the two. And along that axis is where Love Park was placed. The two-tiered plaza takes up an entire city block. In the center, long, wide steps cascade down to a giant circular fountain. Above on the main level, granite planters surround the plaza, as well as lots of rectangular marble benches. It's a space only a modernist or a skateboarder could love. And it's awesome for skating because you can do what we call lines, which is like a series of tricks. So you could do like a switch crook on one of the benches and then a fakie tray flip,
连接两者的对角线大道。Love Park就位于这条轴线上。这个两层的广场占据了整个城市街区。在中心，长而宽的台阶倾泻而下，通向一个巨大的圆形喷泉。在上面的主层，花岗岩花坛环绕着广场，还有许多长方形的大理石长椅。这是一个只有现代主义者或滑手才会喜欢的空间。它非常适合滑板，因为你可以做我们称之为“线路”的动作，也就是一系列技巧。所以你可以做一个switch crook在其中一个长椅上，然后做一个fakie tray flip，
and then if you wanted to you could do like a switchback tail on another part of the park. Oh and the granite tiles can even be pried up to make little ramps to launch off of. The park was conceived for the late Edmund Bacon as part of his undergraduate thesis at Cornell. He later made the park a reality as the executive director of the Philadelphia City Planning Commission with the help of architect Vincent Claim. Ed's been a big deal in the architecture world since the 50s when he shaped how Philly looks today. His vision for the city even put him on the cover of Time Magazine. He also happens to be the father of Kevin Bacon. Really?
然后如果你想的话，你可以在公园的另一部分做一个switchback tail。哦，花岗岩瓷砖甚至可以撬起来做成小坡道来起跳。这个公园是为已故的埃德蒙·培根构思的，作为他在康奈尔大学本科论文的一部分。他后来作为费城城市规划委员会的执行主任，在建筑师文森特·克莱姆的帮助下，将公园变成了现实。埃德自50年代以来在建筑界一直是个大人物，当时他塑造了费城今天的样子。他对城市的愿景甚至让他登上了《时代》杂志的封面。他恰好还是凯文·培根的父亲。真的吗？
Now you're one level away from Kevin because you're talking to me, though. And I'm actually, wait, that'd be two, right? Actually, I think that's four degrees. This is the closest I've been in that game. This is very exciting. So there you go, my friend. I'm happy I could help you there. Bacon's design turned out to be perfect for skateboarding.
现在你离凯文只有一级之遥了，因为你在和我说话，虽然。等等，那是两级，对吧？其实，我认为那是四度。这是我在那个游戏中离得最近的一次。这非常令人兴奋。所以给你，我的朋友。我很高兴能帮到你。培根的设计结果证明对滑板运动非常完美。
And then the 80s, when skating took to the streets, the timing was perfect for skaters to claim Love Park as their own. You know, there was kind of a suburban migration. There was less interest in density. And so places like Love Park were kind of sitting there, not being used. In the early 90s, skaters started filming themselves at Love Park, and the videos found
然后是80年代，当滑板运动走向街头时，时机对于滑手们将Love Park据为己有来说非常完美。你知道，当时有一种郊区迁移。对密度的兴趣减少了。所以像Love Park这样的地方就那样坐落在那儿，没有被使用。90年代初，滑手们开始在Love Park拍摄自己，这些视频找到了
their way to the epicenter of the skate world, California. Suddenly Philadelphia was a destination for skaters. And as the skateboarding industry grew, so did the popularity of Love Park. By the late 90s, pro skaters moved to Philly just to skate it every day. They built their careers shooting photos for glossy skateboard magazines at the park. You could even virtually skate there in Tony Hawk's famous video game. So as an awkward 14-year-old passing through Philly on vacation, I was like, Dad, we gotta go to Love Park.
它们通往滑板世界中心——加利福尼亚的路。突然间，费城成为了滑手们的目的地。随着滑板产业的发展，Love Park的受欢迎程度也随之提高。到了90年代末，职业滑手们搬到费城，只为了每天在那里滑板。他们通过为光鲜的滑板杂志拍摄照片在公园里建立了职业生涯。你甚至可以在托尼·霍克著名的电子游戏中虚拟地在那里滑板。所以作为一个尴尬的14岁少年，在度假经过费城时，我说，爸爸，我们必须去Love Park。
So I got to skate the ledges and stairs I saw in videos and on my PlayStation, while my dad read the newspaper by the fountain. I wouldn't be that excited again until I got my braces off. Even though Love Park was like Mecca, it was never legal to skate there. I don't think it's legal to skate at Mecca either. Skaters would get tackled by cops, ticketed by undercovers, or have their boards taken away. by undercovers or have their boards taken away. And the area was gentrifying. Finally in 2002, Philly Mayor John Street took the skateboard ban a step further and
所以我得以在我在视频和PlayStation上看到的壁架和楼梯上滑板，而我爸爸在喷泉边读报纸。直到我摘掉牙套，我才再次感到那么兴奋。尽管Love Park就像麦加，但在那里滑板从来都不合法。我不认为在麦加滑板也是合法的。滑手们会被警察扑倒，被便衣开罚单，或者滑板被没收。而该地区正在绅士化。最终在2002年，费城市长约翰·斯特里特将滑板禁令更进一步，
renovated the park. The major thing that they did was they removed all of the granite benches, these great skatable elements, and they replaced them with, you know, kind of Williams and Sonoma-ish looking wood benches that looked like they belonged on 1890s kind of park. To disguise this decoration, the new features were meant to make it harder for skaters to use the ledges or to cruise from one end of the park to the other. So they took away the wide open paved areas and tried to replace them with grassy spaces in between.
翻修了公园。他们做的主要事情是移除了所有的花岗岩长椅，这些很棒的可滑元素，取而代之的是，你知道，那种看起来像Williams and Sonoma风格的木制长椅，看起来像是属于1890年代的公园。为了掩盖这种装饰，新功能旨在让滑手更难使用壁架或从公园的一端巡航到另一端。所以他们拿走了宽阔的铺设区域，并试图用中间的草地空间来代替它们。
You know, adding some landscaping, adding an actual lawn was a good idea, but the design result was kind of horrible. It's just a very uncomfortable space and not a space that people want to use. People protested the renovations. There were rallies and newspaper articles. One story read, the mayor blindly took a route of time-honored Philadelphia tradition in destroying a source of pride and fame, hard-earned by its own citizens. A big skateboard shoe company called DC even offered up a million dollars to keep the park the way it was, and to kind of offset any damages skaters might have done over the years. The city of Philadelphia declined the offer. City counselors and architects like Tony spoke out too.
你知道，增加一些景观，增加一片真正的草坪是个好主意，但设计结果有点糟糕。这只是一个非常不舒服的空间，不是人们想要使用的空间。人们抗议翻修。有集会和报纸文章。一篇报道写道，市长盲目地采取了一种费城传统的路线，摧毁了一个由其公民辛苦赢得的骄傲和名声的源泉。一家名为DC的大型滑板鞋公司甚至提供了一百万美元来保持公园的原样，并抵消滑手多年来可能造成的任何损害。费城市拒绝了这一提议。市议员和像托尼这样的建筑师也站出来反对。
There would have been a way to make some significant adjustments to Love Park that would accommodate other kinds of activities without totally compromising skateboarding and come up with a successful evolution of the space. I think that that would have been possible. I think politically that would have been too difficult. Love Park drew people to the city. Philadelphia even hosted this big skateboard competition called the X Games, the two summers prior
本来有一种方法可以对Love Park进行一些重大调整，以适应其他类型的活动，而不会完全损害滑板运动，并提出空间的成功演变。我认为那是可能的。我认为在政治上那会太困难。Love Park吸引了人们来到这座城市。费城甚至举办了名为X Games的大型滑板比赛，就在
to getting rid of Love Park. But unlike traditional sports, skateboarding's kind of hard to control and difficult to monetize. And that's usually a little scary to the squares, but not to Ed Bacon. Bacon was thrilled that his space was evolving. Here he is from a 2006 documentary
摆脱Love Park之前的两个夏天。但与传统运动不同，滑板运动有点难以控制，难以货币化。这通常会让那些循规蹈矩的人感到有点害怕，但对埃德·培根来说却不然。培根很高兴他的空间在演变。这是他2006年纪录片中的片段
called Freedom of Space. I think skateboarding is a far more profound revolution than people give it credit for. The wonderful thing to me is that these young people discovered that they themselves would creatively adapt to the environment they already found, and that it was their joy to adapt themselves physically to what was already there. Bacon was so against the renovations and crackdown on skaters in his park he staged his own protest. On October 8th, 2002, with the media there, two people propping him up on either side
名为《空间的自由》。我认为滑板运动是一场比人们给予的评价要深刻得多的革命。对我来说，美妙之处在于这些年轻人发现他们自己会创造性地适应他们已经发现的环境，并且能够物理上适应已经存在的东西是他们的快乐。培根非常反对翻修和对公园里滑手们的打击，他组织了自己的抗议活动。2002年10月8日，在媒体在场的情况下，两个人扶着他，两边各一个，
and a blue bicycle helmet on. A white-haired trench coat clad 92-year-old Ed Bacon rode a skateboard in Love Park. Held up and pushed along on a skateboard might be a more accurate description. And now I, Edmund N. Bacon, in total defiance of Mayor Good of Ghana, in total defiance of the Mayor Street and the Council of the mayor street and the council other city of Philadelphia
戴着蓝色自行车头盔。92岁的白发苍苍、穿着风衣的埃德·培根在Love Park滑了滑板。被扶着并在滑板上被推着走可能是一个更准确的描述。现在我，埃德蒙·N·培根，完全无视加纳的市长古德，完全无视斯特里特市长和费城市议会，
hereby exercise my rights as a citizen of the United States and I Deliverately skate in my beloved love park Oh God, thank you, thank you, thank you Oh god! Thank you, thank you, thank you! My whole damn life has been worth it just for this moment. The ugly pink planters and William and Sonoma benches stole Gray Slope Park. But so does a plaque memorializing Ed Bacon, and people still skateboard there, and they still get chased by cops.
在此行使我作为美国公民的权利，我故意在我心爱的Love Park滑板。天哪，谢谢，谢谢，谢谢！天哪！谢谢，谢谢，谢谢！我这一辈子都值了，就为了这一刻。丑陋的粉红色花坛和Williams and Sonoma长椅偷走了Gray Slope Park。但纪念埃德·培根的牌匾也一样，人们仍然在那里滑板，他们仍然被警察追赶。
Skaters now figure out ways to work around the redesign. Something Ed Bacon would probably be proud of. Love Park isn't the iconic spot it used to be, but Skate Park started copying features from its original design. There's a good chance that if a skate park was built in your area in the last 10 years, it'll have a knee-high, modernist style bench, or maybe even those same cascading long steps like the ones at Love Park. You'll also see things like hubbos, like we talked about earlier, or even a low block
滑手们现在想出了绕过重新设计的方法。埃德·培根可能会为此感到自豪。Love Park不再是它曾经的标志性场地，但滑板公园开始复制其原始设计的功能。如果你的地区在过去10年里建了一个滑板公园，它很有可能有一个膝盖高的现代主义风格长椅，或者甚至像Love Park那样相同的倾斜长台阶。你还会看到像我们之前谈到的hubbos，甚至是一个低矮的混凝土块
of concrete beside a small set of stairs. We call that a Pier 7 ledge, named after another San Francisco spot. These are all design elements that were dreamt up by some well-meaning city planner, and they're now worshipped by skaters. Tony, the architect we heard from, is now working on a skate-friendly city plaza that's right near Love Park. I gotta admit, part of me thinks these designated places to skateboard kinda miss the point. It's like running a marathon on a treadmill. It's not exactly the type of thing that'll get you on the cover of runners world But guys like Tony are legitimizing skating to designers and to architects He gets it a skatepark is now something that real architects can have a hand in But part of the excitement of street skating is happening upon that spot that wasn't meant to be skated
在小楼梯旁边。我们称之为Pier 7壁架，以旧金山的另一个场地命名。这些都是由一些好心的城市规划师构思的设计元素，现在被滑手们崇拜。我们听到的建筑师托尼现在正在设计一个靠近Love Park的滑板友好型城市广场。我必须承认，我的一部分认为这些指定的滑板场所有点偏离重点。这就像在跑步机上跑马拉松。这并不是那种能让你登上《跑者世界》封面的事情。但像托尼这样的人正在让滑板运动在设计师和建筑师眼中合法化。他明白了，滑板公园现在是真正的建筑师可以参与的事情。但街头滑板的部分兴奋感在于偶然发现那个本不打算被滑的场地，
But seems like it was built exactly for a certain trick. It's like found art. That's why we're still hunting for spots in the streets. Pro skaters now fly out to China for three weeks at a time to skate the new sprawling marble plazas that seem to pop up there on a daily basis. And because skateboarding isn't as popular there, the war on skaters hasn't seemed to reach China yet. Modernist architecture appears, then skaters, then skates stoppers. And in a way, without really knowing it, we're kind of critiquing the design. Skaters say, we don't care what you made it for,
但看起来它正是为某种技巧而建的。这就像现成的艺术。这就是为什么我们仍然在街头寻找场地。职业滑手现在一次飞往中国三周，去滑那些似乎每天都在那里涌现的新兴宽阔大理石广场。而且因为滑板运动在那里不像那么受欢迎，针对滑手的战争似乎还没有波及中国。现代主义建筑出现，然后是滑手，然后是滑板挡块。在某种程度上，在不知不觉中，我们正在批判这种设计。滑手们说，我们不在乎你是为了什么制造它的，
this is how we're using it. And when you land a trick there, it's like a secret victory. You put your own mark on a place. And now even us Squares can read those marks too. That story originally aired in 2013 and was produced by Andrew Norton and Sam Greenspan. 99% of visible was reported this week by Christopher Johnson, edited by Emmett Fitzgerald, mixed in sound design by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real, fact checking by Graham Haysha. Kathy too is our executive producer, Delaney Hall is our senior editor, Kurt Colestad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Perube, Jason De Leon, Vivian
这就是我们使用它的方式。当你在那里完成一个技巧时，就像一场秘密的胜利。你在一个地方留下了自己的印记。现在即使是我们这些循规蹈矩的人也能读懂那些印记。那个故事最初于2013年播出，由安德鲁·诺顿和萨姆·格林斯潘制作。99%不可见本周由克里斯托弗·约翰逊报道，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音和声音设计，斯旺·里尔配乐，格雷厄姆·海沙事实核查。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑，库尔特·科莱斯塔德是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·佩鲁贝、杰森·德·莱昂、薇薇安·
Lay, Lashamma Dawn, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, Sarah Bake, Jacob Moultonato-Medina and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of the logo was graded by Stefan Lawrence. I also want to give a quick shout out to the nine club podcast. We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building and beautiful uptown Oakland, California. If you haven't already, pick up your copy of the power broker by Robert Caro and you can join our power broker discussion book club new episodes come out every month right
莱、拉沙玛·道恩、乔·罗森伯格、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、凯利·普莱姆、莎拉·贝克、雅各布·莫尔托纳托-梅迪纳和我，罗曼·马斯。99%的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯设计。我还想向Nine Club播客致敬。我们现在是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，总部位于北边六个街区的Pandora大楼，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。如果你还没有，买一本罗伯特·卡罗的《权力掮客》，你可以加入我们的权力掮客讨论读书俱乐部，新剧集每个月都会发布
here on this feed. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, plus we have just added a new 99PI Discord server. So come and join me and the rest of the team to talk about Power Broker, you can talk about architecture, you can talk about books, talk about movies, as long as you're nice, you can talk about whatever you want to. You can find a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
就在这个订阅源上。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，此外我们刚刚添加了一个新的99PI Discord服务器。所以来加入我和团队的其他成员讨论《权力掮客》，你可以谈论建筑，你可以谈论书籍，谈论电影，只要你友善，你可以谈论任何你想谈论的事情。你可以在99PI.org找到该链接以及99PI的每一集过往节目。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。